[Music]
the goldsmith national championship
would be to win it I was the 2017
national champion so be sweet to keep
that flag and keep that going into the
next year
Nutrition factors into the goals and
kind of reaching those goals by
nourishing your body you make sure
you're putting the right supplements in
your body if it's a morning race I would
generally keep it oatmeal eggs in the
morning go out race and kind of have a
snack just during the race during some
of the World Cups I would use the
science in sport go energy bars not
really look so much for a whole food to
just keep it light and not have to eat
something so heavy the science it's for
products being certified by informed
choices is definitely valuable to myself
as an elite athlete with all the strict
testings we have to go to being at the
level that we're at and you know that
it's it's clean just picking it up off
the shelf or when you're using it and
you don't even have to get on the
internet and search that's definitely a
big thing for me and in deniz knowing
that what I'm taking isn't gonna pop
dirty or anything on race day I
definitely want to be taking the right
supplements making sure your
electrolytes are good I would say the
scientists for go electrolyte works best
for our kind of training you can use it
either to pre hydrate and hydrate
throughout the event or your training
day kind of pre training free vein and
definitely during the event it works
well to keep your electrolytes up and
make sure you don't get dehydrated
[Music]